doit on y va
m
vous avez des enfants ce n'est pas le
problème c'est un pot commun
ce que je suis sûr que dans votre
fauteuil la bien aimée
persuadé vous savez tout ce qui se passe
dans ma tête de vote car à ce que vous
lui avez assez rabâché qu'il fallait pas
parler aux inconnus encore moi monter
dans la voiture d'un étranger
c'est une étiquette de fanta je vois pas
la tête de diable un tel moment tout le
temps là tu pars trop l'emmène que si
par hasard quelqu'un de gauche venait de
lui parler pour lui demander d'aller se
faire éclater la gueule 4000 kilomètres
d'ici vient alors il dira à son papa et
sa maman je veux que tu sois moi je vais
pure théorie pure je n'ai pas comme tout
ce qui t'entoure jeu spécial j'avais
comme une force en moi qui me poussait
qui monte c'est qu'il faut faire ça tout
bien tout ira bien
qu'est ce que fait mon pays pour tous
ces enfants qui sont en train de partir
du centre n 2 masculine
vous vous avez comment j'essaye
apprendre à vivre sans raisonnement sans
ce rationnelle
vraiment incompréhensible
non
you